Spider-Man's Marvel Cinematic Universe
journey began way back in 2016
as a part of the ensemble film
"Captain America: Civil War."
In the years since he has found great
success and failure — certainly doing
more than previous live-action incarnations
of the web-slinger ever had a chance to.
He's gone toe-to-toe with Earth-bound
supervillains, faced down the Mad Titan,
Thanos in a bid to save the universe, and
even came back from beyond the grave. However,
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" presented him with
arguably his biggest challenge yet in the MCU.
Following a magical, multiverse-collapsing
mishap courtesy of Doctor Strange,
several iconic Spider-Man villains
poured into the main MCU timeline.
Standouts from Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man"
trilogy Green Goblin, Dr. Otto Octavius,
and Sandman returned to the
silver screen, but that's not all.
Foes from Marc Webb's "Amazing
Spider-Man" films reemerged as well,
those being the Lizard and Electro. The latter
got quite the makeover this time around,
but simultaneously left fans scratching
their heads by the time the credits rolled.
The MCU Spider-Man three-quel was a
mind-bending, continuity-straining event,
and while it was a ton of fun to reconnect
with all the old heroes and villains,
it did result in a few confusing moments.
Fans will likely be unpacking all the various
plot conflicts created by "No Way Home" for a
generation, but there's one in particular that we
just can't shake. There's a big Electro-related
plot hole in "No Way Home." Here's what it is.
As noted previously, the reason why so many
Spider-Man rogues from across time and space
converged on the MCU Earth had to do with Doctor
Strange's botched spell. As he tried to magically
force the world to forget that Peter Parker is
Spider-Man, the wall-crawler in question kept
talking and breaking his focus. Seems like Tom
Holland has trouble keeping quiet in any reality.
As a result, Strange's cast went
haywire, and before he could contain it,
a few sinister bad guys slipped through the
cracks. According to the former Sorcerer Supreme,
the flub brought over people who knew that Peter
Parker and Spider-Man were one and the same.
That goes a long way toward
explaining the rogues' gallery
that our Spidey trifecta had to face off
against, but there is one outlier here.
This concept makes sense for all of the villains
except Electro. Fans of the Garfield-starring "The
Amazing Spider-Man" flicks will likely recall that
Foxx's electrified baddy never actually learned
his Spidey's secret identity during his sole
previous appearance in "The Amazing Spider-Man 2."
Perhaps this little detail simply slipped
through the cracks — there is a lot of
continuity to wrangle, after all — but Electro's
ignorance of Spider-Man's identity actually made
it into the script. The villain addresses it
explicitly in "No Way Home" when he mentions
that he always thought Spider-Man was
Black. So, what's really going on here?
The easy answer is that Marvel Studios and
Sony simply wanted to play to the fans and
give Jamie Foxx another chance to portray
Max Dillon. As for in-universe explanations,
fans have begun to pull some ideas
together to explain this plot hole away,
which is awfully generous of them.
Referring to a line by Electro in "No
Way Home" concerning what he was doing before
he jumped to the MCU, on Redditor posted,
"Assuming Strange was right about the spell,
perhaps Max absorbed some data that
gave him Spider-Man's identity."
Another user also brings up an interesting
idea in the same Reddit thread, stating,
"Most likely the villains of No Way Home were
pulled from universes that have history extremely
similar to but not quite identical to the
events of the Raimi and Webb Spider-Man movies."
Octavius' inability to recognize his
friend Curt Connors as the Lizard and
Sandman constantly maintaining his
sandy state — totally flying in the
face of their Raimi incarnations
— lend credence to this theory.
There's also the solution that a few people
brought up, claiming that perhaps Strange didn't
fully understand the spell or misinterpreted it
in some way. There's also the timeless answer
that Electro slipped into the MCU because comics
are crazy and any attempt to explain away every
little asynchronous detail is a fool's errand.
Regardless of the true answer, we can only hope
that somehow a future MCU installment
will put this Electro plot hole to bed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "No Way Home"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.